cardinals took to the field a little
early so johan has finished up the
warm-up tosses and just standing now
waiting for our first pitch you know
what
i don't love him standing around waiting
but i do love the fact that he was ready
to rock and roll digging in to get it
started jonathan india let's play reds
and cardinals in st louis you can
and but you also want to be able to stay
back
and not back too far because
oviedo may take your chin off that's a
ball four here's tyler naquin who is a
invitee to spring training after
spending time in cleveland and now he's
batting cleanup
one two hit up the middle there's sosup
and a scoreless top of the first the
lead off walk
and india left stranded see if the bats
can't get going today
they take on tyler o'malley his numbers
from western and southern
tyler malley comes into the start with
10 and a third consecutive scoreless
innings
in his last two starts combined 17 major
league wins against
27 losses the pitch to edmond a swing
and a fly ball
hit to the gap deep left center field
back to the wall
and off the wall tommy goes into second
with a leadoff double
he got a double in his last at bat last
night driving in two runs
helping close the gap only to have
cincinnati win by two for the second
straight day
but edmond is beginning to heat up
back-to-back strikeouts after the double
by tommy edmond
and we'll see if nolan aronado can break
out nolan over the last week is
two for 26. the o2
reaches out base head into right field
on an o2
there comes edmond he will score
punched it out to right one nothing
cardinals a two out base hit nolan
aronado
on the baseball kids look at his head
his head is right down at contact
no it's not his pro prototypical double
in the gap swing
but you protect with two strikes you get
ahead early that's huge
with the the young johann oviedo on the
bum here's molina good numbers against
mali 474 in his career and a couple of
home runs
a 3-2 pitch the runner goes the pitch is
strike three called on the outside
corner yachty thought he had ball four
and says something to andy fletcher
the reds have seen oviedo one time
through the order now
now we'll see if the reds after getting
a look at him can start to
do some damage against him
and that one is turned on oh oviedo knew
it
hammered to left jonathan india again
his second homer in as many days and the
rookie
leading off ties it up one all
he had that five rows behind the reds
bullpen out in left field i mean way out
of here
and winker will settle in and winker
struck out his first timer
on the ground hit hard right to sosa on
the second base side of the bag he'll
make the play
and that'll be the final out for the
reds here in the third tyler
will bat he ground it out sharply to the
shortstop
[Music]
sosa
that one past the outstretched dive of
carpenter
naquin takes a turn throw to second base
he's safe
oh what hustle from naquin and he gets
himself to scoring position
barnhart has 18 rbis and a chance to
give the reds the lead in the top of the
fourth
that one is hammered into center field
to base it nakequin given the green
light carlson from center throws home
no chance naquin slides in backside
barnhart claims second
reds on top two one and another man in
scoring position
you know you know the dylan carlson this
ball hit very well hanging breaking ball
right there
barnhart who's already had a home run in
his career off of oviedo
hits it solidly up the middle and you
know the carlson's going for it all
right here he's going to throw it over
the cut-off man
barnhart knows that and as soon as he
sees that ball released
he realizes it's not going to be cut and
he goes into second base
goldschmidt arenado molina three four
and five in the cardinal lineup
here's a one-two goldschmidt puts it in
plain down the right field line it is
sinking
and it drops and it gets past castiano's
off the sidewall
goldie to second on his way to third
in there with a triple
and it's arnado at the plate who drove
in the cardinals run
in the first inning
[Applause]
on one and two served into right field
and again he just punched it out to
right
with two strikes he's driven in both
nolan arenado
that'll score paul goldschmidt we're
tied at two
he saw the o1 pitch that he couldn't
pull the trigger on you know he would
love to
this one's a slider this is a really
good pitch
down in the way and he just does a great
job of keeping his head on it
serves it that way suarez
grounded into a fielder's choice hit the
ball back to oviedo
one two hammered by suarez deep left
center field
into the bullpen
[Applause]
hey eugenio suarez connects a two-run
shot
and the reds forge ahead on his mighty
power
it's four to two jesse winker he's set
to lead it off against the left-hander
cabrera
and that's down and you make a great
point there's another walk by this
cardinal bullpen
there's castiano's hit one to the
tracking right
grounded out to third and popped out to
the catcher kisner
hammered through the whole base hit
21-game hit streak for nick
castellanos you can't stop it
now he's hitting the ball hard and he's
hitting it all over the place
fastball that comes on right out over
the center of the plate it looks like
and he just stays right back and uses
his hands
gizner having a discussion with cabrera
cabrera's had a couple instances where
he has been
crossed up on signs too so a good start
to the inning from the reds point of
view a walk in a base hit
but back-to-back strikeouts for cabrera
and looks like he will face
suarez accordion fastball back to the
screen but it goes right back to
kisner a high throw and it goes into
left field
he had him dead to right at third base
and just
threw it away oh my a break for the
cardinals
and it's given right back on the error
by kisner
making sure you take advantage of little
opportunities that come your way
edmond racing over near the line diving
catch
tommy edmond you can count on him
five two our score bottom of the ninth
orinato against sims one for three in
his career with a double and a walk
the two-two orinato puts it in play out
to shallow center and again he finds a
way
three-hit day nolan arnado
[Applause]
tyler o'neal one for three with a double
and hits it the other way
slicing castiano's over can't get it
pops over the wall with a ground rule
double and now
the tying run again and the bottom of
the ninth will come to the plate
just like in games one and two single
ornato strikeout kisner double o'neal
on two on carpenter oh two
swing a miss he struck him out second
k for sims and the reds are one out of
the
way
second and third sosa the tying run at
the plate homer last night his first big
league homer
sky to center sliding grab shogo
wakayama
game winner
[Applause]
sims bolts down the save and the reds
take the series
they can seek a sweep in saint louis on
sunday